[Música]
les quiero contar esta historia que a mí
como florista me impactó demasiado y
considero que es importante que la sepan
un día llegó un cliente a la florería a
pedirme unas flores para su niño de 9
años pero fue muy específico que quería
que le recitábamos esas palabras porque
a él le quedaba muy poco tiempo de vida
en ese momento uno no sabe ni qué hacer
ni quiere decir un momento difícil
se podría decir que un poco crudo pero
al final todo salió bien
semanas después nos llamaron los
familiares para pedirnos que por favor
lleváramos las flores a la niña y en el
momento en que se recitó el mensaje fue
impactante y ahí es cuando me pongo a
pensar el gran poder que tienen las
flores en la vida esa niña cada vez que
vea una flor va a recordar a su papá
cuando era niña recuerdo que me
encantaba ver las flores a donde fuera
siempre quería cortarlas para
regalárselas a mis papás pero
curiosamente había flores que me llaman
más la atención que otras entre una de
ellas era la peor ya la peor ya que sin
su relevancia más que mis propias
convicciones me llamaba la atención
porque era diferentes tamaños y colores
ahora que trabajo con flores me doy
cuenta que la peonía es mi flor favorita
la peón ya es una flor que se
caracteriza por su forma pero sobre todo
el proceso que va cambiando conforme a
los días se va poniendo más bonita
además es la flor con mayor tendencia en
todas las campañas publicitarias de moda
de perfumes de amor todo enamorado
siempre va en busca de esta flor para
poder para regalar a esa persona
especial y también veo como muchísimas
novias desean tener esta flor rodeada en
sus bodas por eso yo me atrevo a decir
que la peón ya es una de las mayores
flores con mayor influencia en este
mundo en la moda es la musa de
muchísimos artistas y diseñadores y la
que ha presenciado muchísimos momentos
importantes del mundo ahora muchos de
ustedes han de preguntar pero por qué
son tan relevantes las flores porque es
que nos llaman tanto la atención pero
como les explico que mi hijo a los 2
años de edad veía flores salía corriendo
y me cortaba una y venía hacia mí y me
decía mamita toma para ti y me da un
beso o sea para mí era hermoso el
sentimiento que él me proyectaba y ahí
te das cuenta que sin sabor el
transfondo social él sabía que las
flores están hechas únicamente para
regalar amor ahora con el tiempo con la
oportunidad que he tenido de trabajar de
crear diseñar me ha dado cuenta que las
flores no pueden faltar en la vida de
las personas hay clientes que van y
compran flores para tener en su casa
porque les generan más tranquilidad
otros
a pesar de los meses de los años
transcurridos
van y compran flores para el nicho para
la tumba de ese ser querido que ya
falleció
las flores son como ese recordatorio de
no te olvido sigues en mi corazón y lo
más padre de todo es que van y las
vienen con una emoción como si realmente
fueran a llevarse las en persona muchos
familiares que están lejos que tienen
años de no verse ayuda en especial que
tiene 20 años sin ver a su mamá su mamá
está bien documentada en eeuu
las flores son de ese pasaporte a su
casa cada día soy mayor
cada navidad cada cumpleaños y ahí te
das cuenta el poder que tienen las
flores se convierten en besos y abrazos
que no se pueden dar desde no sé cuánto
tiempo por eso me atrevo a decir que las
flores tienen un gran gran impacto en el
mundo por ejemplo en la moda va desde
cuando la misma naturaleza nos regala
parte de su composición natural en su
jugo para crear lo que son tintes
naturales hueco prix que funcionan como
para plasmar sobre un algún tipo de tela
de modo que los pétalos queden dibujados
sobre ella entonces cuando ustedes vean
una pieza de diseñador a un precio que
digan oye por qué está tan caro esa
puede ser una de las razones que en vez
de estar pintada con colorantes
artificiales está pintada con flores lo
cual lo hace muy único natural y saben
que sobre todo muy sustentable
ahora vamos a hablar acerca de por qué
las flores las tienen todos porque las
pueden recibir todos
las flores son democráticas son
universales cualquiera las puede comprar
y las puede regalar antes cuando alguien
por no tenía dinero iba al jardín del
vecino y cortaba una flor y salía
corriendo antes de que se dieran cuenta
ahora eso ha cambiado ahora cualquiera
puede tener acceso a comprarlas
regalarlas y eso es gracias a la gran
logística a la gran distribución que hay
porque ahora ya hay más facilidad al
acceso a las flores de ser un lujo se
han convertido en una necesidad de los
seres humanos nos hemos vuelto más
empáticos más unidos buscamos la
felicidad del otro sobre todo esta
sacudida en los últimos dos años no se
nos ha demostrado que el mantener el
amor y a la gente unida es lo más
importante y las flores son eso ahora
así como las flores son naturales
también conllevan un cierto proceso de
innovación para que la gente les atraiga
yo les voy a platicar una experiencia
que tuve cuando recién inicié
a mí me encanta el color negro me
fascina se me hace muy muy de moda muy
elegante y un día se me ocurrió comprar
una pintura vegetal y pinte unas rosas
negras y a mí me encantaba tener la
solicitación un día se me ocurrió tomar
la foto y lo subí a la página
bueno si vieran la respuesta que hubo
sea hubo tantos comentarios negativos
como positivos muchos decide oye puso de
luto es una burla cómo vas a mandar una
fuerza hacia una persona pero por el
otro lado hubo gente que digo wow yo
quiero una se ven súper fashion pues ahí
es cuando te das cuenta que como
florista tú tienes la oportunidad de
diseñar y de crear pero el cliente es el
que le da la intención por eso me atrevo
a decir que ustedes son los que pueden
darle el significado a la flor sin
importar si es amarilla si es negra si
es roja
ahora con el crecimiento de las redes de
comunicación redes sociales como
facebook o como twitter el tóxico
twitter que todos decimos nos damos
cuenta que es una manera de expresar lo
que sentimos pero ninguna se va a
comparar con el lenguaje las flores las
flores son aduladoras son románticas son
bonitas cada vez que ustedes la reciban
jamás va a ser un insulto hacer todo lo
contrario va a ser puro amor las mismas
glorias que existían hace 500 años son
las que existen ahorita yo me pongo a
pensar a mí me encanta tener tulipanes
rojos siempre en mi casa me siento de
los veo los disfruto igual que bonitos
están y me pongo a pensar que a lo mejor
hace muchísimos años
mozart tenía los mismos en su casa o en
el lugar donde componía y a lo mejor se
pudo haber llegado a inspirar en una de
sus composiciones que ahora escuchamos y
todo eso es gracias a través de las
flores
otro ejemplo maría antonieta a lo mejor
era fanática de las peones como yo hoy
también se emocionaba al verlas y al
olerla eso no quiere decir nos da a
entender a todos de que las flores son
el concepto universal de la belleza de
las flores nos conectan con nuestros
antepasados con nuestras generaciones
nos conectan con el mundo por eso yo a
todos ustedes les quiero los quiero
invitar a que vean las flores con esa
pasión que la sientan que la disfruten
que cada vez que ustedes manden flores
vean todo el proceso positivo que
ustedes están están enviando las flores
están hechas únicamente para alegrar
tanto los ojos de uno como los
sentimientos de las personas
ahora que hayan visto esto que estén
aquí salgan y digan a esa persona que
tanto quieren lo que sienten corta una
flor y un jardín vayan y compren una en
el semáforo hagan lo que sea pero nunca
se queden con eso guardado y utilicen la
belleza de las flores para transmitir
eso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]